on ne la voit plus que duo désert ou
presque marie gopaul une ville
martyrisée dans l'horizon n'est plus
qu'un terrifiant fantôme
ceux qui restent piégés par les bombes
et l'encerclement des troupes russes se
terrent dans les sous sols encore
habitable et meurt lentement de faim
fuir cet enfer par ses propres moyens
c'est ce que vient de faire irina contre
toute attente elle a pu démarrer le
moteur de la carcasse de sa voiture des
motocyclistes lui ont offert ce casque
pour la protéger d'un froid qu'elle a dû
endurer sur des centaines de kilomètres
est pourquoi je ne comprends pas qu'une
question
pourquoi
vous qui n'ont été ni parcours général
streicher les premières bombes sa maison
détruite l'absence d'électricité d'eau
de nourriture de la vie dans les sous
sols sans aucune nouvelle de ses proches
elle croit encore les avoir rêvé ce
qu'elle sait c'est qu'il lui fallait à
tout prix sauver sa vie et celle de sa
fille c'est
juste avant de partir elle a retrouvé sa
mère dont elle était sans nouvelles dans
un quartier voisin mais son père lui est
resté derrière sa tante aussi il est en
anglais
1-3
du côté ukrainien
personne ne viendra les chercher les
gens là bas le savent
cet hypermarché des apories gea s'est
transformé en premier accueil pour ceux
qui risquent eux tout pour sortir de
mario paul
cattier à dégage un calme tout aussi
improbable que son sourire apaisant
c'est la première fois qu'elle peut
changer la couche de son nourrisson de
13 jours sans s'inquiéter pour sa vie
vladimir est né alors que le plafond du
séjour s'effondrait sous les obus
le
corridor
[Musique]
nous y passent leur temps à lire comme
vous seraient disponibles aux
imaginales ça fuse la majorité arrive
ici sous le choc épuisée visiblement à
famille
des
états voisins étaient à prostate
dans les hôpitaux des apories j'allais
blessures physiques des rescapés de
mario paul dissimulent leur âme tout
aussi meurtri natalia a mis plus de dix
jours à pouvoir sortir son mari d'un
hôpital maintenant occupée par les
russes il est fort dit elle mais il ne
peut rien raconter sans fondre en larmes
céline quoi nous offrir
cette chance dont parle natalia celle
d'être sorti vivant n offre aucun
soulagement aussi beaucoup sont partis
en emportant avec lui la culpabilité
celle d'avoir laissé les leurres
derrière quand il en a été blessé son
père lui est mort sur le champ elle a dû
se résoudre à laisser une partie de sa
famille à mario paul
moreau
et à
dominique ou génie à bord d'un bouchon
minya parce que y'a rien à perdre et
coaching il dit en échappée mais la mort
continue de hanter les dortoirs des
hôpitaux de zappos rija kamina a été
blessé dans un bombardement
elle était terrorisée à l'idée de partir
mais à marie gopaul elle n'aurait pas
survécu
je te tue mouches qui touche à tout ça
que voir tout à travailler les leviers
pas comme on le dit une connerie tu
crois que
ça va rester comme ça toi mon adhésion
on ne retrouvera jamais ce que l'on
cherche dit galina ils ont vécue avec
fierté toute leur vie pour finir
enterrés dans des fosses une comme des
chiens à mario paul tout est mort y
compris l'humanité y la dignité